we've been playing a whole lot of MORTAL
KOMBAT 11 yes we have and I want to talk
to all y'all about story crit how the
combat feels all the extra stuff on the
side but let's first talk about the
combat and how that combat feels no yes
it feels real good like man I'll be
playing Jackson soccer fools but because
those metal arms yeah the sound design
overall like not just with Jackie's
metal arms but every single punch just
feels so impactful and it takes lend a
lot for that I think and the other
really big thing coming from playing a
lot of the older games is animations
Mortal Kombat haven't been that smooth
or that sure I guess good is it as a way
to put it but these ones are actually
great like you can feel character's
weight shift after they come out of like
a kick it's all kind of really well
thought out and really well done and
that's kind of the big thing for me it
really helps the visual flow because
everything feeds into the next thing
nothing feels choppy when you're
actually like seeing it it also relates
to the frame timings of the attacks like
if you can see that visually like oh I'm
like I'm ready to go or this is like I
can see the recovery time of my attack
when I do because animations flow so
well and they're very they communicate a
lot but it is a little weird playing a
lot of more combat 11 codes like Max and
I play a lot of anime fighters yeah we
move fast like we want them air dashes
we're Tombaugh we're 1-1 off the ground
there's no dashing and MK 11 and
everything just feels a lot chunkier
that's not a bad thing necessarily but
it's very different it's a lot to get
used to especially I played a bunch of
blades we've crossed tag max time we're
playing that the other day and were like
oh my god this is so much going on right
there but yeah moving to MK 11 I still
like the way it flows even if my
expectations are a little bit different
so like max I'm going to this like how
does it how's it feel to play something
that's so much more slower pace the
anime fighters that play you know
there's mostly jump cancel bulls there's
lots of blocking the air so chicken
blocking that kind of stuff feels like
there's a lot more freedom
so there's definitely two types of
fighting games this one has been a
little more tough on my head because of
that this makes a lot more like brain
trappy
neutral pressure comes yeah yeah and I
know where we're dropping a lot of
fighting game terms what
Mortal Kombat 11 does more so than any
other game that I've seen or at least
any other fighting game I've seen is
that tutorials are so robust so yeah
we're talking about frame timings we're
talking about I'm thinking about like
zoning and pressure and what it like a
lot of people plannin come into this
game like what does that even mean well
you know the tutorial explains
everything for you also puts you in the
situations to kind of get acquainted
with it cuz I play online I'm getting I
get my husband beating down on the
corner I'm like damn what am I doing
wrong so then I go back to the toriel
and be like what am i what am I missing
what are the pieces that aren't coming
together for me when I'm playing
competitively and having the tutorial as
not just a way to teach you but it's
also a resource to refer to when I lose
like ten matches in a row which has
happened yeah my bad just being able to
constantly teach myself and remind
myself all I have this option I can
break away like if I'm getting juggled
you get out of it there's a way together
I can do a breakaway and there's just a
lot going on with the gameplay I mean I
don't know if you've ever seen this type
of tutorial and fighting it before no
definitely not like the in-depth stuff
like usually they don't explain like the
frame delay is like how much or active
frames are like best specific
information is usually not shown in
tutorials and most fighting games so
that is pretty interesting on Mortal
Kombat support to put that much effort
into this game for sure so yeah I think
the thing that really sticks out for me
is outside of the general tutorial being
as robust as it is is when you do the
character specific tutorials it's not
just here on this characters moves it
does here's this characters move it's
best to use in this situation when
you're proposed with this kind of thing
and it gives you more than just here's
the move it gives you the context or the
move when you want to do it and how you
should execute it I think that's really
valuable information and I kind of wish
more fighting games did that yeah I know
you're putting together a bunch of
combos for video purposes but uh I'm
struggling a little bit with trying to
string extended combos together because
of like the chunkiness and sort of the
pacing of it I mean it's
the games fault is just me trying to get
used to it but for you yeah there's
definitely assistant to it you know the
amplification is definitely helping the
juggling part like you said it's like
extending strings there's definitely a
better starting moves there you know do
more damage you know crushing blows that
kind of stuff yeah that special cancels
like going from a regular combo into a
special move so that all comes together
really flows really well so combo system
actually works pretty well in this game
that heard that supposedly this is less
combo here than other Mortal Kombat's
I mean it's been great so far yeah it's
really well built yeah the thing I
notice is like it's beginner-friendly as
deep as it goes a lot of beginners can
come into this and figure it out you
know even like having a comeback
mechanic that's not types of meters with
the fatal blow it's like I can just
press the triggers and I'm gonna take
out like 30% of your health straight up
if I'm when I move down 30% or less
health so there's a lot of cool small
things that they're doing to the combat
system that just makes it a lot more fun
to engage with even on a competitive
level they're not that great and if
you're more of a casual player there's
still a lot more stuff for you to do
particularly with the story
[Music]
we silage you know no I played most or I
played all that story and man that's a
tree it's a whole cinematic story mode
and if you're familiar with another
realm games like they did it with
injustice they did with previous combats
9 and 10 but there's something special
about this one I think it's in the
character models and like the delivery
of the lines and just kind of the set
pieces and a lot of the callbacks to
these characters you think you've known
for like 25 30 years for example like
katana is best girl she's my favorite
character in the game dude and she gets
puts she gets put in like so many cool
situations and it's just a really cool
moment where Kung Lao and Liu Kang or
have this bromance going on and I went
on an adventure together like yeah yeah
Edmund Tran mentions this in his review
is it like one of the highlights of
story mode is like liu kang kung lao
being like best bros yeah did it of
course she did they're just like this
really cool dynamic between liu kang and
katana throughout
but also Jackson Jackie going to a lot
more family history and that's because
of this timeline the sort of time
mutilation with chronic Oh who's the
main villain and then you'll see things
like Johnny Cage and Johnny young Johnny
Cage dealing with older Johnny Cage is
probably my favorite part just because I
love Johnny Cage as a character so much
yeah but seeing the dynamic of like
older Johnny Cage being like off why is
he like this what's wrong with him and
trying to like straighten out and be
like yeah don't say that disown you're
like be nice to her what do you know
yeah old Johnny's like yeah dog and he's
like pulling them by to hear and all
that it's so many good moments with that
dad always said hungry people eat lunch
humble people serve it dad was an
[ __ ] Hollywood made us and even
bigger one a lot of players should play
the story mode not just cuz it's great
but you also got a bunch of coins that
you can spend for cosmetics cuz one of
the big draws for MK 11 is how much
cosmetic stuff there is now at the time
of this discussion right now though the
ROM was in the process of kind of
changing things up because our only
experiences with the launch style of the
Crypt which has been I guess a little
shaky that I suppose can crisis have
been real high the the whole economy
balance of it all is what they're
looking at I guess I haven't felt that
bad about it because I've just been
constantly grinding things out the Crypt
itself is an interesting concept an idea
and I really like how they've done it
this time around where it's actually
kind of like a third-person adventure
game you're going on in solving puzzles
and you're finding all these really cool
references to not only all their games
but there's a lot of callbacks to the
old movie which I really kind of like
geeked out over a lot at one point I
found the actual bucket of water that
Liu Kang uses to defeat sub-zero in the
movie and I blew my mind but I kind of
like the process of slowly uncovering
more about the world there's like story
they're kind of you'll you'll run into
coming in corals layer and you'll see
Goro sitting there dead on the throne
like things have happened here and
there's a lot of stuff to kind of figure
out through your adventure and unlock so
it's more than just concept art and
character skins
fatalities brutalities affined there's
there's kind of a cool story to do I
kind of find it a little frustrating
though the way the the unlock stuff is
structured like the Crypt like I said is
like a cool concept but you know opening
chests and spending coins and like
having all these different currencies is
just it's I don't know I don't for sure
yeah it's very tedious there's like
usually like with randomized stuff like
that it's it's a loop box you could just
kind of get it over and over and over
again that's that's the big thing - yeah
all the loot boxes are randomized yeah
and you had to go search for them yeah
and sometimes they'll have like key
items inside of them that you need or
you'll need to pull items from outside
of the crypt into the grip to be able to
progress so I think there's you get an
amulet for finishing the tutorial for
the living towers I figure what they're
called exactly it does have the towers
of time towers time you get an amulet
from that that you then take back to
repair a statue in the actual crypt to
progress the story in there and it's
kind of weird to kind of try to put your
pants on exactly what you need to be
doing because there's no way to kind of
track it but yeah I'm not a fan of the
way unlocks working at least they're not
tied to premium currency the way premium
currency is works it's like the time
crystals you buy them you can earn them
but at a pretty slow rate in the game if
you also buy them and they're just like
certain items that you purchase in the
store so there's no randomization with
the monetization
[Music]
yeah you mentioned the towers time which
is supposed to be like a big draw for
the game but at least that launched not
the best that they can be they're like
they're very difficult if they feel
cheap yeah oh all the foots are very
very one-sided you'll have a setup where
you come in here ok cool I've got a
fight
Liu Kang and Kung Lao cool that makes
sense the Shaolin monks let's do it
and then when you get any of them down
to 30% of their health all of a sudden
rockets start falling from the sky and
there's a blizzard so you get frozen in
the air there's no reason it's not fun
it's gotten to the point where I'll
actually just have my a eyes go through
it while I'm trying to do other things
because I don't want to like deal with
it
they're also addressing that as well
you're like conceptually the towers of
time it sounds like a cool idea but in
practice the the variables and
modifications that they throw at you to
spice up the fights yeah it as being
more frustrating than challenging and
less fun yeah but that's also a way to
get a bunch of unlocks because you get
it you got a lot of currency finishing
those towers you also get a bunch of
gear or two for completing brutalities
gear a lot of stuff just call yet that's
written thing to like unlocking the
second fatality and the brutalities
through finding stuff in the crypt oh
yeah locking in towers like what yeah
I don't know I'm not feeling that it's
my it's a bit of a weird thing for sure
[Applause]
just to wrap it back around though like
we're enjoying our time with MK 11 but I
also want to touch on the competitive
aspect again because I think that speaks
to the longevity of MK 11 so I mean I'm
playing some online matches I haven't
had any connectivity issues yeah it's
been pretty smooth so far I had a couple
when I was playing yesterday I think
that was at busy servers when there was
first starting but I mean overall it is
definitely a much better online and most
of the fighters that I've seen so far
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I've been having a ton of fun
online and I guess at least the
matchmaking for now has been fairly even
for me like I'm not constantly match it
with people we're gonna whup my ass but
yeah I'm having a blast with it
same it the the combat just feels good
the fighting we got to play a little bit
over over in the speed zone like locally
- which was really fun yesterday it's
it's a great game to play and I'm
excited to see how they updated and
adjusted yeah comes down the road with
like DLC characters yeah because that's
that's really important for a fighting
game to last at least some we're gonna
see it at Evo but I think the longevity
of fighting it really relies on updates
and DLC and how that's handled so here's
hoping that MK 11 has a long shelf life
yeah for sure
you